l'open de france est une compétition
sportive mondialement connue mais le
tournoi est aussi une vitrine
commerciale pour de nombreuses marques
pendant quatre jours un village
d'entreprises s'est installée entre les
greens
les places sont chères pour installer un
stand mais l'investissement ne décourage
pas les sociétés le tarif de base c'est
3000 euros en fait pour exposer et puis
ça montre justement sur le testing
center une face à la boutique ça monte à
peu près jusqu'à 6000 euros donc voilà
c'est des tarifs pour pour exposer et
après parce que ça représente pour une
entreprise c'est aujourd'hui plus grand
événement golf en france c'est la
référence on va dire que l'entreprise
les marques c'est l'événement
incontournable aujourd'hui pour
rencontrer 50000 golfeur c'est ici qu'il
faut être pour cette 100e édition le
village s'est agrandie pour accueillir
soixante exposants ici à la boutique du
golfe la compétition et surtout la venue
de rory mcilroy permet de booster leur
chiffre d'affaires pourquoi avoir une
quand tout d'abord pour faire pour faire
du business très clairement après on est
ici aussi dans cet espace pour
représenter l'open de france et aussi la
ryder cup qui va se jouer en 2018 pour
d'autres partenaires l'open de golf
c'est aussi l'occasion de développer
leur image de marque
c'est le cas de bmw pour nous c'est
important de proposer différentes choses
donc c'est les 100 ans de la marque
cette année donc pour ses 100 ans on a
amené des véhicules historiques on a
présenté on a deux véhicules historiques
on a ramené du musée de munich
on a également des voitures plus
modernes et en plus de ça on a une
boutique life talent on présente nos
au produit donc
lifestyle golf est également donc cette
fameuse voiture sur lola 8 rouges et qui
est pour la première fois présenté en
france dans cette couleur les
partenariats qui peuvent rapporter gros
aux sociétés si cette dernière ne
souhaite pas communiquer sur leur
chiffre d'affaires
elles sont 85 % chaque année à
renouveler leur partenariat avec l'open
de france de golf